Ciao ragazze e ciao ragazzi, questo è un tutorial su come dormono le principesse ehehe
No, non è vero
AHHAHAHHA
Ciao ragazzi, per la prima volta mi vedete senza trucco
E tutto questo soltanto per questo fantastico video
che state per vedere, dove parlerò delle persone quando si svegliano al mattino.
Quindi, siete pronti? 1, 2 ,3 VIA!
Eccoci qua! Spero che il video vi sia piaciuto, ed io sono curiosissima
di sapere se vi siete ritrovate in qualche tipologia,
oppure se voi vi svegliate in una maniera così strana che me la dovete per forza raccontare qui sotto
mi raccomando se vi è piaciuto il video iscrivetevi al canale e seguitemi
su tutti gli altri social
Ciao!